what i want to do in this video is make
sure we're comfortable with ways to
represent and visualize complex
complex
numbers so you're probably familiar with
the idea a complex number let's call it
z
and z is the variable we do tend to use
for complex numbers
let's say that z is equal to a
plus bi we call it complex because it
has a real part
it has a real part and it has an
imaginary part
and it has an imaginary part
and just so you're used to the notation
sometimes you'll see someone write the
real part give me the real part of z
this is a function that you input a
complex number and it'll output the real
part and in this case the real part is
equal to a
and you could have another function
called the imaginary part the imaginary
part of z you input some complex number
it'll output the imaginary part the
imaginary part or it'll it'll say how
much you're scaling up i and in this
case it would be b
it would be b this is a real number but
this tells us how much the i is scaled
up in the complex number z right over
there now one way to visualize complex
numbers and this is actually a very
helpful way of visualizing it when we
start thinking about the roots of
numbers especially the complex roots is
using something called an argand diagram
argand diagram
argand diagram so this is this and so it
looks a lot like the coordinate axes and
it is a coordinate axes but instead of
having an x and y axis it has a real
it has a real
and imaginary axis so in the example of
z being a plus bi we would plot it
really as a position vector where you
have the real part along the horizontal
axis so let's say this is a
and then the imaginary part along the
vertical axis or the imaginary axis so
let's say that this is b and so we would
represent in an argan diagram the vector
z as a position vector that
starts at zero and it has a tip at the
coordinate a comma b so this right here
this right here
is
our complex number this right here is a
representation in our argan diagram of
the complex number a plus bi or of z now
when you draw it this way when you draw
it as a position vector you and if
you're familiar with polar coordinates
you're probably
thinking hey i don't have to represent
this complex number just as kind of
coordinates just as an a plus bi maybe
maybe i could represent this as some
angle here
as some angle here let's call that angle
phi and some distance here let's call
that r which is kind of the magnitude of
this vector and you could if you if you
gave some angle in some distance that
would also specify this point in a
complex plane and this is actually
called the argument of the complex
number and this right here is called the
magnitude or sometimes the modulus or
the absolute value of the complex number
so let's think about it a little bit
let's think about how we would actually
calculate these values
so r which is the modulus or the
magnitude it's denoted by
the magnitude or the absolute value of
z1 what's this going to be
well we have a right triangle here
we have a right triangle here this side
is b
length b the base right here has length
a so to calculate r we can just use the
pythagorean theorem r squared is going
to be equal to a squared plus b squared
or r is going to be equal to the square
root of
a squared
plus
b squared if we want to figure out the
argument
let's say we want to figure out
the argument this is going to be equal
to what so let's think about this a
little bit we have b
and a so what trig what trig function
deals with the opposite side of an angle
and the adjacent sides let me write all
of let me write the famous sohcahtoa up
here soka
toa
tangent deals with opposite over
adjacent so the tangent
the tangent of this angle which we call
the argument of the complex number the
tangent of the argument is going to be
equal to the opposite side over the
adjacent side it is equal to
b over a and so if we wanted to solve
for this argument we would say that the
argument is equal to
the arctan or the inverse tangent of
b
over a
now if we wanted to represent let's say
we had we had the complex number let's
say that we were given the argument and
the let's say that we were given
let's say that we're given the modulus
and the argument let's say we're given
that how do we go the other way right
now if we have the a's and the b's the
real the complex part i just showed you
how to get the magnitude and how to get
the angle or the argument but if you're
given this how do you go the other way
well here if you're trying to figure out
a given r and theta
so you're trying to figure out an
adjacent side given an angle and the
hypotenuse so adjacent over hypotenuse
is equal to cosine
so you would have cosine
of the argument is equal to r
is equal to the
is equal to the adjacent over the
hypotenuse is equal to a
over r multiply both sides by r you get
r
cosine
of phi is equal to a
do something very similar for b
if we use sine opposite over hypotenuse
sine of the argument is equal to
b over r is equal to b over the
magnitude multiply both sides by r
you get r
sine
of phi is equal to b
so how would we write this complex
number so this complex number z
the complex number z is going to be
equal to its real part
which is r cosine of phi
r cosine of phi
plus
plus the imaginary part times i
r let me do that same green plus r sine
of phi
times i
now this might pop out at you as
something that's pretty interesting if
you've ever seen euler's formula let's
factor out this r over here so this is
going to be equal to
factor out an r r times cosine of phi
cosine of phi plus i'll put the i out
front i signify
i
signify now what is this
and if you've seen the videos i do it in
the taylor series a series of videos in
the calculus playlist and it's really
one of the most profound results in all
of mathematics it still gives me chills
this is euler's formula this is or this
by euler's formula is the same thing
this is the same thing and we show it by
looking at the taylor series
representations of e to the
of e to the x and the taylor series
representations of cosine of x and sine
of x but this is if we're dealing with
radians e to the i
phi e to the i phi so z is going to be
equal to r
is going to be equal to r
times e to the i phi
e
to the i
phi so there are two ways to write a
complex number you could write it like
this where you have the real and the
imaginary part that's might be what
we're used to or we can write it in
exponential form where you have the
modulus or the magnitude
being multiplied by a complex
exponential we're going to see that this
can be super useful especially when
we're trying to find roots now just to
make this tangible let's actually do
this with an actual with an actual
example so let's say that i had i don't
know let's say that i had z1
is equal to
let's say that z1 is equal to
square root of let's say it's square
root of 3 over
square root of 3 over 2 plus
plus
i and so we want to figure out we want
to figure out the
we want to figure out its
magnitude and we want to figure out its
argument so let's do that so the
magnitude the magnitude of z1 is going
to be equal to the square root of this
squared so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to three
over four
three 4 plus 1 squared plus 1 squared or
i should say plus 4 4
plus 4 4. so this is going to be equal
to
square root of 7 over 4 which is equal
to the square root of 7
over two
and now let's figure out its argument so
let's draw
if i were to draw this on an argand
diagram
on an argand diagram
it would look like this
it's going to be in the first quadrant
so that's all i have to worry about
so let me draw it
let me draw it
like this
and so we have a situation
so it's going to be square root of 3.
actually let me change this up a little
bit just so the numbers get a little bit
cleaner sorry about this let me make it
a little bit slightly cleaner
so just so that we have
a slightly cleaner result because we
want to make our first
our first example a simple one so let's
make the square root of three over two
plus one half
plus one half i so let's figure out the
magnitude the magnitude here z one is
equal to the square root of square root
of three over two squared is equal to
three over four
plus one half squared is equal to
one-fourth this makes things a lot nicer
this is equal to the square root of one
which is one
and now let's think about it let's draw
an argan diagram to visualize the
argument
so this is my imaginary axis
that is my
imaginary axis
this is my real axis my real axis and so
this complex number is square root of 3
over 2 square root of 3 is like 1.7 so
if we have like 1 it will be like so
this is 1 it will be like right
right over here someplace right over
here this is square root of three over
two the real part the imaginary part is
one half so if this is one this is one
half the imaginary part is right over
here one half
and we actually also know its length its
length or its magnitude is one so how do
we figure out how do we figure out phi
over here we know that this side over
here is square root of three over let me
be careful we know that side over there
is one half that's the imaginary part
and we know the base is square root of
three over two
so a bunch of ways we can do this
one you could just look at you could
just do the tangent because that
involves the opposite over the adjacent
you could say that the tangent
of phi is equal to the opposite is equal
to one half
over the square root of three
over two and then you could take the
inverse tan of both sides so this would
be the same thing as
five being equal to the inverse tangent
or the arc tangent of if you multiply
the numerator and the denominator by 2
this is 1 over the square root of 3. you
could do it like that you could also say
that phi is equal to
the inverse sine of so the sine of phi
is going to be equal to the opposite
over the hypotenuse so sine of phi is
equal to one-half over one or phi is
equal to the arc sine of one-half
and you could put that in your
calculator or you could recognize this
is a 30 60 90 triangle this base right
here square root of three over two this
is one half this is one so this angle
right here is going to be 30 degrees and
that's just from pattern matching from a
30 60 90 triangle you could look at
these and also get something similar now
i want to put this in radian form
because whenever i use the exponential
form you want it to be in radians so phi
is equal to 30 degrees
phi is equal to 30 degrees which is the
same thing which is the same thing as pi
over 6. so if i wanted to represent z1
in exponential form it would be the
exact same thing as r or its magnitude
which is 1. i'll put the 1 out there
even though you really don't have to
1 times
e
1 times e to the pi over 6 i
e to the
pi over 6
i and we're done